[Music]
hey see glad to have you back what do
you know about her just the rumors she
freaked out or something the first
semester Casey you okay I look like a
freak if it wig you are not a freak I
know what it look like you're Casey
right I'm Reagan hi do you already have
a partner for speech you want to partner
with me a year ago my house caught on
fire and my dad didn't make it out this
is all that's left
sorry have you checked Instagram hashtag
most inspirational every year the school
votes for the person they felt had the
most positive impact does that mean I'm
nominated she's coming out of her shell
that's all I wanted we don't really know
her Sylvain okay don't you do it a
school counselor yes it's my friend
those are mine
[Music]
[Music]
Squad is a grow short if you wanted to
share don't you find it weird something
bad happens Casey sign if it's from it
package came for you
Jefferson High I give you 50 years most
inspirational she's playing all of us
some yourself others have tried to take
me down
and it's never ended well are you
threatening me Casey had to go to
counseling for anger and food there's
some crazy stuff in there
it's test you for the new suspect in
fire where did you get this you see how
many people have you enough to keep them
from taking what's mine
[Music]
Jefferson High say hello to the most
inspirational student of the year Casey
Paulson no idea how much this means to
me
you
you